he likes that hat i like that hat too i
got to get one of those now a little
camo
our military heroes the man in service
women who serve our country
and they'll take their swings off of
dean kramer 25 year old right-hander 6-2
205 pounds his last timeout against the
red sox
the number one offense in baseball he
was really good through five innings he
only allowed the one run
got him chased up high for strike three
good start for dean kramer
2-2 pitch bounced on the ground left
side picked up on the uneven bounce by
franco across to first
and voight set down judge heaton up he's
six for his last
11 at the plate with a home run 2-2 that
one is ripped to left field and deep
that ball is gone see ya
a home run for judge and the yankees are
on the board it's one nothing
well we mentioned this is a home run
ballpark and although a judge to get him
out of just about anywhere
he got a slider on the inner half of the
plate and he turned on it with authority
and the yankees are up on nothing eight
rbis
[Applause]
pop-up right side balaka is there and
makes the catch for the out
yankees retired but they get a run on
aaron judge's
ninth home of the year one nothing new
york corey kluber
they are the numbers and they are
improving for corey kluber this is his
eight start two and two record good era
3.06
run it goes throw to second got him
a tag applied by le mayhew and
higashiyoka
gets the first out of the inning boston
hayes 247 for him
four homers 12 driven in more reason to
put him in the lineup that's hit hard
way back in left field that's gone
austin hayes
matches aaron judge solo homer for solo
homer
we are tied at one that's number five
for austin
you talk about one that gets out right
about now i mean it's going two-seam
fastball kluber trying to get on the
inside part of the plate it never got
there austin hayes pulls those hands in
and finds the barrel
grinded softly to second and that will
do it
but the orioles tie the score on the
austin hayes home run we go to the
second
kramer 2-2 to frazier and down goes
frazier
number one second strikeout really
impressive
one-two pitch blooped out to shortstop
galvez moving on to the outfield grass
makes the catch and there's two going
five ball right field
stuart's there and it's a clean one two
three inning for dean cramer
one two strike three
mount castle down looking slider slider
slider
looking for another one not this is
fastball the tails back over the outside
corner
fly ball left field frazier near the
line puts it away
right-handed pedro severino hits a high
pop
to right judge back a step or two
and he makes the catch to end the inning
song on and miss boyd slams the bat down
well dean kramer i tell you what the the
fastball's got some life on it watch
this one 95
just above the top of the strike zone
another slider cut on him as he couldn't
resist it
kluber slided
and the pitch cut out i missed a sinker
away that was
just about on the plate so
second straight strikeout fewest games
to 1500 strikeouts and clippers right
there on the list pretty big names
including the big unit and randy johnson
aaron judge who home in his first time
will lead it out
now here's the two one swung on and hit
in the air to right
that ball is high it is far it is gone
another judgy and blast
oh aaron you are judge and jury
he homers this one to right center and
the yankees take a 2-1 lead
2-2 gardner swings it's a drive towards
left center field hayes out mullins out
diving it bounces in front of mullins he
can't come up with it but now the
yankees
are caught in a rundown here brett
gardner touches first clint frazier is
still standing at first
and so frazier is going to be out the
yankees have
caught themselves time and time again
this season with
base running errors
now here comes a slider to a left-handed
hitter and freddie galvez who's been
swinging about pretty well lately
swing and a miss a one two three inning
for corey kluber
he has retired eight in a row
where they felt like he was got him to
chase upstairs
down on strikes kluber in the first
inning gave up a home run to hayes
and that's it and he has been brilliant
looper into center field judge coming
hard
did he get it i'm not sure stewart going
to second
and he's out well judge has been
fighting a little bit of a leg injury he
certainly trapped that ball no doubt
about it but d.j stewart thinking double
the whole time the question is
did he get in or not wait a minute
ball's out the ball is out he's in there
safe yeah tying run now 90 feet away
and it'll bring severino up to the plate
the 2-0
there's a breaking ball loop down the
left field line
fair ball rolls into the corner this
brings home stewart
severino digging for second he will chug
in there
it's an rbi double which ties up the
game at two in the fifth inning
as severino comes through after stewart
opened the inning with a two bag here's
pat felika the number nine hitter at
second base
tonight up the middle base hit
severino around third has the green
light gardner
will throw to second and the orioles
have the lead pat
valenka comes through it's 3-2 orioles
two on two down mancini first pitch
swinging
right field corner judge over can't get
it fair ball
one runs in to score here comes valencia
round third here comes the throw to the
plate
and he is out tried to jump it but the
orioles
are up four to two and the pinch hitter
georgella
high fly ball deep right center that
could go
see ya a pinch hit three-run home run
for gia or shella and the yankees lead
5-4
[Applause]
a little bit right of dead center geo
oshella
the most happy fella the stewart
will start against peralta and there's a
base hit
so he's reached all four times tonight
three base hits and a walk
d.j stewart gets it going lead off
batter got on and now he passes the
baton
can the yankees turn two there's one
and there's two they turn the double
play
around the horn in a hurry and the
orioles suddenly down to their final out
and the pitch popped up
this should do it voigt's there and the
yankees win five to four
a come from behind victory in the first
game of this three-game
set and a classic at back by giorshella
a pinch-hit
three-run home run and that's enough for
the yankees
two home runs by aaron judge kluber gets
the win the yankee bullpen does the job